it was different you know learning a new
system i feel like uh
you know coach gruden's is a new age
condensed playbook so i've mastered the
first thousand pages only got about 9
000 more to go
jason witten new raiders tied in talking
about a playbook that that chris sims
once had to master or at least try to
master
uh what did do you get like the shakes
what do you do when you hear about that
gruden playbook what's your visceral
reaction oh well i just you know i mean
really it's it's like it's good memories
even though i struggled saying a lot of
it like here's our my old you know
uh three seven right x that's about
shift to viper
sims you idiot chris what [ __ ] day
are we living in green right at shift
the viper right 382x stick look oh no
green right x shift the viper right
three to two x stick looking i'm already
probably don't have all day
damn
whoa all right well i can tell you i'm
sick of seeing that damn thing come
about every ten months
every ten months that coat catches like
social media fire and uh yeah that was
that was rough well you know because
here's the thing here's the thing yeah
you're like you're like a foot taller
than him why didn't you just go like
that i wish i would have i listen
there's one thing i i wish i would have
been a little bit of a tougher
personality you know we've always we've
always talked about that how like you
know the squeaky wheel gets the grease
or oil whatever the hell they say uh you
know sometimes i wish i did stand up to
him a little bit more he probably would
have liked me more he wanted you to
probably i think that's what they're
trying to get i think that's what
they're trying to get derek carr to do
yes i think that's where he is in his
career where they were trying and maybe
they would have gotten you there if if
you hadn't had
the situation in 2005. maybe you would
have matured to that point you would
have eventually just stuffed him in a in
a trash can and and reacted the way he
wanted you to i was getting there you're
right though i was i think i showed
glimmers of it to him in 2005. and then
yeah in 2006 in training camp a few
times i know i gave him a few side looks
and like told him hey shut the you know
blank up and all those type of things um
but you know by the time i really grew
into okay i'm not afraid to question him
or talk back a little
i was hurt and not playing good so i had
nothing to stand on and he didn't want
to hear it from me then then he was like
well now you're a disgruntled untown
talented football player get the hell
out of here uh but but derek carr yeah
he'll have to grow into that and that
offense is not easy it's it's a lot of
words
what was the go-to play from the gruden
playbook the one that you knew if you
had to get that first down you dial that
up it's gonna work well yeah it depends
on the yards you know listen we got into
like third and two or less you know old
spider two why banana was gonna be part
of the conversation okay but you know 72
scat half back choice where you let the
back run out of the backfield and work
the weak side linebacker one on one you
know i always tell you one of the big
plays in my playoff run here's a wordy
one for you you've heard me say this
before west right slot 72 z bingo you
split can it with 58 lexus apple 314
hammer that was one play so you had to
be ready for all those things and then
grooting couldn't be wrong if that
messed up it was me i was the idiot who
didn't read the defense rate
how do you get that play call out when
there's a clock ticking
down to when you have to snap the ball
lots of practice in in a crucible with
70 000 people loud if you're on the road
how do you get everyone to hear that
lots of
him yelling at me and being napoleon at
practice you know telling me a play and
going hurry up ten nine so it just was
drilled into you and yeah you had to get
that play i'd get in the huddle and you
know i'd look at i i kill your go give
me a dummy dummy motion and i'd go west
right slot 72 z counter orbit 72 z bingo
you split can it 58 lexus 314 hammer
dummy snap count on one and then i was
walking to the line of scrimmage i'd say
rocker rocker because of john rocker
right you remember the pitcher for the
braves he was a dummy so that was my
code word they let everybody know about
snapchat rocker i'd have defensive
players after the game go why did you
say rocker and tyson so much and i go
well they're dummies so we'd use them
for a dummy snapchat
you know i heard that the derek carr has
a sims
i'm sure i'm sure gruden probably has
had a lot of bad plays in the book named
after me
let's let's take a break peter king's
gonna join us next with some insights
into a day in the life at texans
training camp you won't want to miss
that more pfd live coming right after
this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports